[Musique]
Michel Colomb bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle S VI on aurait voulu avoir
votre regard sur la géopolitique
actuelle qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire première question qui
êtes-vous je suis écrivain et
journaliste indépendant en dehors du
système des médias j'ai commencé à
travailler euh après une carrière comme
une carrière c'est un vilain mot mais
après un travail comme journaliste sur
les social en Belgique puisque je suis
basé à Bruxelles ou à Liège et j'ai
commencé à travailler sur ce qui est
devenu mon thème central les guerres les
stratégies de guerre et les stratégies
de désinformation pour moi ça va
ensemble avec un livre qui s'appelait
attention média sur la première guerre
du Golf contre l'Irak attention média
forcément je me suis pas fait que des
amis encore que il y a eu quand même un
intérêt de la part de certains services
publics on va dire surtout sur euh vous
savez en 90 91 ça a été le fait festival
des médias mensonges et de la
désinformation au courours de la guerre
de d'Irak au cours de la guerre d'Irak
les couveuses volé dans une maternité
c'était bidon Sadam husin avait provoqué
une marine noire et Michel Chevalet sur
TF présenté par Poivre d'Arvor disait
regardez Sadam Hussein comme il est
méchant il a fait
délibérément
envahir le golf là par une marinoire de
per vous pouvez délayer l'histoire des
des bébés dans les couveuses l'histoire
des bébés dans les couveuses c'était
ceci ça se passait en novembre
90 et à une commission d'enquête
dépendant du Congrès aux
États-Unis il y a une jeune fille de 15
ans qui vient témoigner en disant voilà
elle pleure toutes les larmes de son
corps et elle dit j'étais
euh infirmière à cowit City la capitale
occupée alors par les troupes
iraakiennes depuis de 3 mois et travaill
dans cette maternité et un jour les
soldats irakiens sont venus ils ont pris
toutes les couveuses il y en avait 32 et
ils ont jeter les bébés par terre et
comme CTA des prématurés forcément les
condamné à une mort atroce et donc voilà
les iraakiens c'est vraiment une
occupation épouvantable donc la jeune
fille la jeune fille c'était son père
c'était et la jeune fille donc euh
forcément c'est une histoire qui a été
popularisée miterran en a parlé bouch en
a parlé amnestie a fait des rapports le
vol des couveuses c'était donc un
argument de choc pour dire il faut aller
euh écraser ce Saddam Hussein qui
n'éparne même pas les bébés et après la
guerre évidemment tous les journalistes
quand le kit est libéré de l'occupation
on va dire tous les journalistes se
précipitent à la maternité on va avoir
un scoop on va vooir les confidences de
tous ces médecins qui ont assisté à ça
et le les médecins disent nos couveuses
elles sont là il s'est rien passé il
s'est rien passé du tout tout la jeune
fille était en fait la fille de
l'ambassadeur du kwait à Washington à
l'ONU elle est à New York pardon à l'U
elle était pas plus infirmière que vous
et moi elle avait passé toute sa les
dernières années là avec son père et
c'était une totale mise en scène par une
firme qui de public relations qui
s'appelle hen nton il y en a toute une
série aux États-Unis qui font ça et en
fait c'est quoi c'est des films de comme
qui se charge de donner une image
positive à des gouvernements étrangers
Israël fait ça l'AR l'Afrique l'Arabie
Saoudite oui l'Afrique du Sud faisait ça
autant de la
part-tête et le kwiit faisait ça
évidemment donner une image positif du
kwiit c'était pas évident donc on a
plutôt fait dans la diabolisation de
Saddam Hussein et on a complètement
fabriqué cette histoire de des couveuses
volées et ça c'est un festival de Médi
mensonge que j'ai donc là on est dans ce
bouquin on était en 91 ouis ça c'est le
point de départ de mon travail là-dessus
et après 91 vous êtes arrêté sur quoi
mais après il y a eu la guerre contre la
youoslavie en deux phases d'abord en Bos
en Croatie Bosnie 91 à 95 puis en
99 la guerre soi-disant pour libérer le
Kosovo et en réalité pour détruire la
youoslavie qui était un pays indépendant
une armée indépendante qui voulait pas
entrer dans l'OTAN et un pays où il y
avait pas mal de choses qui n'allaient
pas mais il y avait aussi des choses qui
allaient pas mal et notamment il y avait
une sécurité sociale importante il y
avait une sécurité d'emploi dans les
entreprises les travailleurs élisaient
leur directeurs donc ça quand les
multinationales ont euh quand il y a eu
la chute du Mur la chute du socialisme à
l'est la Yougoslavie était le seul pays
qui résistait et qui se mettait pas à J
devant les multinationales donc j'ai
montré dans deux livres poker menteur et
Monopoly le temps à la conquête du du
monde qu'en fait c'était une guerre de
recolonisation des zones qui avaient été
perdues et donc moi je travaille sur ça
euh sur ce tableable j'avais pas prévu
au départ de faire ça mais le livre
attention média a très très bien marché
c'était la première fois qu'on faisait
une analyse critique de médias en Europe
il y avait eu aux États-Unis Herman et
schomski qui avait publié un bouquin qui
m'avait inspiré qui était très important
qui s'appelle manufacturing consent la
fabrication du consentement c'està-dire
qu'ils avaient fait un genre de test
média il analysait la couverture des
deux camps dans les grands médias des
États-Unis quantitativement déjà euh et
puis aussi qualitativement dans
l'analyse et ça ça m'avait inspiré et
j'avais décidé d'appliquer ça à cette
guerre du golf en
90-91 et après euh comme ça a eu
beaucoup de de succès beaucoup d'impact
les gens étaient très curieux sur
justement est-ce que les médias me
manipule à ce moment-là euh ben les
États-Unis n'ont pas arrêté de me donner
du travail puisque euh à cette époque-
là on nous avait annoncé un nouvel ordre
mondial il y aura plus de guerre et
cetera et depuis les guerres se sont pas
arrêtées et donc j'ai couvert ça puis la
Libye puis d'autres et c'est devenu un
peu ma spécialité de base comme écrivain
on va dire donc la propagande de guerre
stratégie de guerre et la propagande de
guerre donc la stratégie de guerre
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire de
Carl von closwiitz oh j'en suis pas un
spécialiste
mais je vois que
la guerre se déroule sur différents
terrains et en fait moi je dis toujours
les guerres ne commen pas par des bombes
mais par des médias mensonges et je
pense qu'il y a maintenant du côté des
États-Unis oui surtout une stratégie de
guerre globale la guerre se déroule en
réalité face à
l'ennemi direct déclaré on va envahir
tel pays pardon on va pas l'envahir on
va protéger des minorités ou écarter un
un danger terroriste ou euh voilà mais
en réalité il faut viser pas seulement
comme on le prétend les dirigeants de ce
pays il faut diriger viser pardon la
population qui n'a pas forcément envie
d'être colonisé ou recolonisé et puis il
faut viser l'opinion publique
international et donc pour que les
États-Unis ou la France en Afrique
puisse déclencher une guerre le premier
enemi c'est l'opinion publique
intérieure il faut absolument la
neutraliser il faut l'empêcher de
s'opposer à cette guerre parce que quand
on regarde dans le passé il y a eu
beaucoup de guerres qui ont été arrêtées
ou freiné par la résistance
internationale dans ma génération on a
été marqué par la guerre l'agression des
États-Unis contre le Vietnam qui a
commencé en 61 qui a duré jusqu'en 75 et
elle a été freinée pourquoi les
États-Unis ont mis le paquet hein
c'était à l'époque la plus grande
puissance économique financière
militaire de l'histoire on peut dire il
avait jamais un arsenal militaire pareil
et le Vietnam c'était quoi un pays de
paysan c'était un pays pauvre de paysan
très peu développé à cause du
colonialisme et donc à la fin c'est
David qui a gagné c'est Colet qui est
parti la queue entre les jambes parce
que un les Vietnamiens étai bien soudé
on va dire avec des dirigeants honnêtes
ça ça comp beaup coup pas corrompu qui
avait vraiment une vision de la
Libération qui avait aussi vraiment une
vision d'unir toutes les forces
possibles av les communistes les
bouddhistes les chrétiens euh des
différentes classes sociales contre
l'occupation et de le facteur qui a
permis que les États-Unis soient vaincu
c'est la mobilisation internationale on
faisait des manif pour contre la guerre
au début il y avait quelques centaines
de personnes et finalement on a eu des
manifes de centaines de milliers de
personnes et les États-Unis ont été
complètement mqué là-dessus donc
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
autour d'une affaire qui s'appelle
l'affaire du Golfe du Tonquin ah oui
intéressant ça moi je dis que chaque
guerre commence pas par des bombes mais
par un médiat mensonge et dans le cas de
la baie du
Tonquin les États-Unis c'était Johnson
je pense à l'époque avaient décidé
d'intensifier le leurs opération et ils
ont dit voilà
euh les deux navires ru dans la baie du
Tonquin ont été attaqué par les
vietnamiens et donc nous ripostons ça
c'est un classique de la propagande de
guerre c'est jamais nous qui attaquons
c'est les méchants qui attaquent et nous
on est dans en légitime défense et après
les États-Unis ont reconnu que
l'incident de la baie du Tonquin avait
été complètement inventé et fabriqué de
toutes pièces chaque guerre est basée
sur un méd mensonge et ça c'est quelque
chose que j'ai analysé pour l'Irak pour
la Yougoslavie pour la Libye un gros
truc qui est monopolisé dans la
communication de guerre et qui doit
faire basculer l'opinion ù il faut faire
quelque chose est-ce que vous avez
entendu parler d'une opération qui
s'appelle l'opération Northwood
oui c'est l'IRAC c'est le avec le
contragate ça
c'est à peu près la même époque c'est
autour de Cuba on en reparlera ah oui je
mettrai les
liens très bien donc les médias
mensonges à la base d'une guerre pour
retourner l'opinion publique
on est en 2016 qu'est-ce que vous avez
relevé en ce moment comme média mensonge
bah sur les guerres il y a deux choses
un
on ressasse les médias mensonges des
guerres précédentes qui ont pourtant été
complètement démasqué et ça c'est
frappant sur la Libye par exemple que
j'ai suivi puisque j'ai été deux fois
là-bas pendant les bombardements j'ai
fait une enquête j'ai fait un livre qui
s'appelle Libye autant immédiat mensonge
et là moi je disais à l'époque
un c'est basé sur des médias mensonges
de d'origine à savoir que Kaddafi aurait
euh bombardé euh la population qui
manifestait c'est complètement faux
c'était une invention de que il aurait
envoyé des containers de vieagraas
pour stimuler ses soldats pour violer en
masse comme instrument de terreur de la
population ça c'est un classique euh les
viols de guerre c'est un classique de la
propagande Guay évidemment quand j'ai
été euh en en Libye et que j'ai raconté
cette histoire ils m'ont rayonné en
disant VI grave on connaitt pas nous
c'est le gingembre et ça n'a c'était
complètement bidon
et ça c'est au niveau des médias
mensonges justificateur et puis j'ai dit
à l'époque dans les premiers articles et
puis après il y a eu ce livre j'ai dit
c'est une guerre évidemment pour le
pétrole de Kaddafi c'est une guerre pour
les réserves très importante il y avait
30 milliards de revenus chaque année du
pétrole pour des pays en crise comme les
États-Unis et la France c'est un butin
j'ai dit c'est l'or de Kaddafi qui est
placé dans les banques des États-Unis et
qui vont
jamais rendre et c'est pour empêcher
kadfi de financer des projets de
développement alternatif de pays
africains pour échapper à au chantage
des multinationales et du FMI évidemment
monu c'est un comploteur il voit le mal
partout bien sûr que les États-Unis et
Sarco font une guerre human
et maintenant dans les emails révélés de
Madame Clinton elle dit oui c'est un
Sarco il faisait la guerre parce qu'il
voulait le pétrole et il avait des
accords pour Total et deux c'est un
bonne raison de faire la guerre à
Kaddafi pour son magot son or quoi ouais
l'ORD de Kaddafi ça représentait combien
oh c'était c'est des sommes très
importantes parce que la Libye était un
des je veux plus oser dire un chiffre
mais je l'ai mis dans mon bouquin mais
je suis mauvais sur les chiffres mais
c'était très important pour une raison
bien simple la libe é un des rares pays
au monde sans dette oui non mais il a il
y a il y a ça non mais certes alors
c'était intéressant nous moi j'ai suivi
l'aspect plutôt sur les fonds souverains
H qui représente beaucoup plus en masse
de de de dollars si je peux parler en
terme de masse de dollars que le la
réalité de leur physique de de kadfi je
pense que les fond le fond souverain
libien d'investissement étranger était
beaucoup plus important que oui oui
absolument d'accord donc la Libye la
Libye ça s'est fait euh la
Syrie au niveau médiia mensonge ben
c'est quelque chose qu'on a suivi dans
le site investi action et notamment en
publiant les travaux les enquêtes de
barre kimongur qui est un Belge
d'origine turque mais de la communauté
proche de la Syrie et qui suiv qui a
suivi ce dossier en permanence et en
fait oui on a eu comme d'habitude des
médiasmsonges pour justifier euh en fait
une guerre qu'il voulait mener contre la
Syrie mais par des des méthodes
indirectes et les médias mensonges
c'était not
de montrer des cadavres et des choses
bien atroces comme on fait toujours dans
chaque guerre
pour jouer sur les émotions du public et
de dire voilà c'est Bachar qui l'a fait
et dans beaucoup des cas de de photos
qui ont été publiées c'était l'inverse
je ne dis pas que les troupes de Bachar
étaient ce sont des anges toujours il y
a eu des des atrocités il y a eu des
crimes c'est incontestable mais très
souvent on montrait des photos en disant
voilà les victimes de Bachar mais non
c'était des soldats tués par les
rebelles justement ça c'est très
frappant au niveau des armes
chimiques personne n'est des anges dans
ce conflit mais il y a une chose qui est
il faut toujours voir à qui ça profite
ce genre de chos le moment où ça se
passe c'est le moment où les
l'opposition est rebelle est en grande
difficulté sur le plan militaire c'est
le moment où
où la Syrie a accepté que vienne une
mission de l'ONU pour une mission de
bons Office pour mettre fin au conflit
et juste à ce moment-là comme par hasard
sous les yeux des inspecteurs Bachar
aurait été utiliser des armes chimique à
quelques kilomètres de l'endroit où ils
sont donc ça c'est c'est un truc
classique en réalité il y a eu beaucoup
de documents des
États-Unis et notamment de smour Ch
journaliste d'investigaction extrêmement
important aux États-Unis il a beaucoup
de confidence de l'establishement
militaire qui a dit non non ça c'est
complètement bid vous parlez vous parlez
des États-Unis
euh est-ce que vous avez suivi l'affaire
de l'anthrax des des des mails d'anthrax
qui était qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en
dire les principes de la propagande de
guerre c'est de cacher l'histoire cacher
les intérêts économiques diaboliser
effrayer inverser la victime et l' et
l'agresser et monopoliser le débat
censurer les informations adverses dans
la
diabolisation il faut absolument
flanquer la trouille c'est quelque chose
que Michael Moore a bien montré dans
Bowling for Columbine où il montre que
bouche dans sa croisade pour attaquer au
départ il voulait attaquer encore
beaucoup plus de pays que'est ce qu'il
n'a fait il avait vraiment besoin de
flanquer la trouille au citoyens des
États-Unis avec le terrorisme et
évidemment ce ce cinéma sur l'antraxe et
sur les armes de destruction massive
tout ça c'est au même moment ce sont des
recettes il y a je parlais des public
relations il y a des psyops en
Grande-Bretagne et aux États-Unis là
c'est même assez ouvert en France existe
aussi voilà des experts de la
manipulation psychologique et ces
gens-là sont des pros c'est-à-dire que
ils analysent quels sont les thèmes qui
peuvent marcher pour flanquer la
trouille ou pour justifier une guerre je
sais pas si vous avez vu un film qui
s'appelle W the dog aux États-Unis qui
est un film très intéressant où un
président c'est déjà dans les années 90
je crois un président est en déclin dans
les sondages parce que il a couché avec
une fille et cetera et ça se peut pas
là-bas et
il il faut absolument qu'il remonte
l'élection c'est bientôt il doit
remonter dans les sondages donc ces
experts en com et en psof décid il faut
un ennemi le problème c'est que pour le
moment il y a aucune tension
particulière il y a pas d'ennemi il y a
pas vraiment de gros conflits donc on va
fabriquer un ennemi et quel pays ça peut
être celui-là non et ca et donc
finalement on décide que ça va être
l'Albanie et on va être l'Albanie parce
que personne la connaît on sait même pas
très bien où c'est et donc on va pouvoir
fabriquer et alors je crois que c'est
DeNiro ou Hoffman je sais pas mais il y
a donc un scénariste de Hollywood qui
est chargé de fabriqué et il invent des
images où on voit une petite fille avec
des flammes derrière et un pauvre petit
chat et donc c'est tourné en studio mais
s'est présenté comme étant la pauvre
petite fille qui échappe aux atrocités
des méchants il faut que les États-Unis
aillent protéger cette pauvre petite
fille et son chat et le film est très
intéressant parce qu'il il montre
vraiment la fabrication de l'ennemi la
fabrication de la trouille et bien
entendu à la fin le scénariste est
assassiné parce que il ne faut pas qu'on
sache le président ça marche le
président remonte dans les sondages et
bien entendu le scénariste do mourir au
milieu de tout ça de tout cette
propagande de guerre comment se situe la
France vous avec votre nationalité belge
comment vous nous voyez les
Français bon les Français ça n'existe
pas je sais pas si vous parlez de
Hollande de Vals et de BHL ou si vous
parlez des gens qu'on vient de
rencontrer dans la rue c'est ça g vous
et moii oui ben je pense que
malheureusement
les Français ont un gouvernement qui
travaille contre leurs intérêts quels
sont les intérêts des Français les
intérêts des Français c'est que c'est
d'avoir du travail d'avoir un revenu
correct pouvoir donner un avenir à ses
enfants pouvoir se payer des soins de
santé et avoir une vie un peu correcte
ce qui est financièrement et
techniquement tout à fait possible il y
a bien assez de richesse qui sont
produites pour que tout le monde vive
bien on est dans une situation situation
pardon abominable maintenant la moitié
des gens travaillent comme des dingues
et sont stressés font des heures supes
et prennent des pilules pour tenir le
coup et l'autre moitié des gens sont au
chômage sous-employés et prennent des
pilules parce qu'ils sont en déprime il
faut absolument organiser la vie
économique sociale en fonction des
besoins des gens et pas en fonction des
profits de quelques multinationales ça
c'est un système infernal l'intérêt des
Français comme des Belges et comme de
tout le monde à mon avis c'est de vivre
bien de vivre correctement il y a déjà
une première mesure qui devrait être
faite puisqu'il y a pas du travail tout
le monde parce que heureusement les
techniques les technologies
l'informatique ont progressé on doit
travailler beaucoup moins qu'avant mais
on partage le travail tout le monde
travaille 20h tout le monde sera content
et on pourra s'occuper de ces gosses de
la culture voyager faire du sport ce
qu'on a envie ça c'est l'intérêt des
gens un jour un jour je discutais avec
quelqu'un qui est censé avoir un cerveau
bien fait il m'a dit tu sais
euh c'est j'ai balancé mon n Le la la
démographie nuit à la qualité des
cerveaux qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me
dire de cette phrase là la démographie
nuit à la qualité des cerveaux il veut
dire que s'il y a trop de si on fabrique
trop de gosses on sera plus bête ou je
sais pas je n'ai pas la réponse il
faudra lui demander à lui mais pour
revenir à à la question
importante l'intérêt des Français n'est
pas le même que l'intérêt du 1 % qui
accumule des fortunes je pense à et relo
qui P l'Afrique je pense Dr qui fabrique
des instructions de mort et qui sa'est
fabriquer une fortune là-dessus je pense
à des gens comme qui licence si des gens
à tour de bras il accumulent des
fortunes dont ils savent pas quoi faire
l'intérêt des 99 % il est exactement
contraire au au intérêts du 1 %. et on a
de plus en plus de fortune on a 85
personnes qui possèdent autant que la
moitié de l'humanité c'est un système
absurde ça peut pas continuer les gens
peuvent pas être heureux dans un système
comme ça et le problème c'est que les
guerres sont des guerres pour le 1 %
parce que qui a intérêt à aller
contrôler les minerais en Afrique le
pétrole au Moyen-Orient les marchés et
les forêts l'eau et cetera qui a intérêt
vous moi non nous on peut très bien
vivre avec ce qu'il y a ici et en aant
des relation normale équitable
fraternelle avec les autres peuples mais
les gens qui ont besoin de toujours plus
de fric pas pour le plaisir ou parce
qu'ils sont méchants mais parce que
s'ils le font pas le concurrent va les
éliminer regardez toutes ces fusions de
multinationales toutes ces boîtes dont
l'unique obsession c'est d'être les
meilleurs d'éliminer les autres de les
avaler et d'être toujours plus gros et
ça sert à quoi ça sert à produire des
trucs inutiles de gaspiller les les
ressources de la nature et rendre les
gens malheureux soit parce qu'ils
travaillent trop soit parce qu'ils ont
pas de travail c'est ça qui doit changer
et les guerres sont malheureusement une
manière de faire main basse sur les
matières premières les marchés la main
d'œuvre aussi donc c'est des guerres
pour le 1 % donc comment se positionne
la France autour de tout ça la France
est suivie la France essaye de louvoyer
pour essayer de faire entendre sa voix
la France se trouve ça est-ce que c'est
une question importante c'est une
question d' français ça mais forcément
elle est important alors forcément
mais bon la France
a eu en fait l'élite française a deux
tendances il y a une tendance qui
voudrait bien garder son précarré en
Afrique sa zone d'influence et qui est
essayerait d'être plus indépendante par
rapport aux
États-Unis dans le sens il y a eu un
moment donné des tendances en France et
en Allemagne à faire une
euroarmée qui serait indépendante de
l'OTAN et ça j'en ai parlé dans le livre
monopolie l'OTAN à la conqué du monde
que les États-Unis il y a eu des textes
de volfovitz des textes de P et cetera
qui est de brginski aussi qui disait il
faut absolument empêcher l'Europe
d'avoir son armée et d'être indépendante
d'ailleurs la guerre de contre la
youoslavie dont on a parlé précédemment
c'était pas seulement une guerre contre
la Yougoslavie c'est une guerre pour
empêcher la France de s'entendre avec
l'Allemagne et avec la Russie pour que
l'Europe devienne indépendante donc il y
a cette tendance là dans l'élite
française et il y a aussi la tendance
Sarco Hollande et cetera qui s'est
complètement aligné sur les États-Unis
complètement j'exagère mais qui s'est
aligné sur les États-Unis et qui pense
que en étant le numéro 2 là-dedans il y
aura des bons morceau du gâteau à
récupérer en quoi il se fout le doigt
dans l'œil parce que quand la France
possède et contrôle une colonie et des
richesses en Afrique les États-Unis
finanent des politiques et surtout des
mouvements pour déclencher des guerres
civiles et déstabiliser ça donc les
États-Unis font semblant d'être allié
avec la France en Afrique mais en
réalité il lu la poignère dans le dos
régulièrement comment se comportent les
médias autour de tout ça c'estàd qu'il y
a bien une analyse médiiatique c'est on
a compris que ces médias mensonges
seraient ou semblent être
construit par des cabinets de spin
doctor ou de de de de de de propagande
médiatique payé euh le journaliste du
service public belge ou français ou
portugais espagnol il se comporte
comment face à ça il a encore son esprit
critique d'abord la question est-ce
qu'elle porte sur les médias ou sur les
journalistes les deux et ben c'est pas
du tout la même chose parce que Al le
journalist les journalistes est-ce que
c'est eux qui décident dans les médias
moi je fais toujours la distinction je
crois qu'il y a différentes catégories
de journalistes il y en a des qui sont
très curieux et honnêtes et qui
essayeraient vraiment de faire passer
des choses le problème c'est que dans
les médias c'est pas le journalistes qui
ont le pouvoir c'est le patron tout
simplement comme dans toute entreprise
et il faut voir que au niveau
international et au niveau français
c'est très clair qui possède les grands
quotidiens ou les grandes télé ce sont
tous des milliardaires vous
avez marchand d'armes vous
avez Pier de la
vous
avez marchand d'armes vous
avez qui qui est des personnes les plus
riches en Israël vous avez vous avez
tous ces gens-là donc l'info que les
gens reçoivent que les 99 % reçoivent
est faite par les 1 % en fonction de
leurs intérêts alors vous allez me dire
oui mais c'est pas parce qu'il est
patron qui va mettre à la porte le
journaliste qui lui déplaît bien si on a
plein d'exemples justement où o des
journalistes n'ont pas pu exprimer ou
ont été carrément virés un exemple qui
est pas révolutionnaire de gauche dans
Paris Match quand genenestar qui était
le rédacchef ou le directeur je crois à
l'époque publie des photos montrant que
la femme de Sarco est pas allé voter à
la fameuse élection présidentielle de
2007 ce qui est une info franchement un
petit peu anecdotique il est viré pour
ça parce que Sarco téléphone et
directement le patron vire le le
reddacchef Pr des preuves de ça oui ça a
été reconnu c'est Alain Genestar ça a
été tout à fait reconnu oui absolument
donc c'est le patron qui décide et je
vais mais l'analyse comme je parlais
tout à l'heure de Herman et schomski ils
ont amené une analyse importante qui est
que l'info elle est filtrée de
différentes manières il y a pas que la
propriété il y a aussi la publicité
c'est-à-dire que maintenant vous pouvez
lancer un quotidien mais supposons qu'on
le vende à 1 € ou 1,50 € en réalité le
coût fabrication est deux à trois fois
plus important ça veut dire que c'est
pas en payant votre quotidien que vous
le payez c'est l'annonceur qui paye le
quotidien ça veut dire que en fait on
vend un acheteur à un annonceur et les
budgets de la publicité c'est quoi c'est
le pétrole c'est les bagnoles c'est
prooring Gamble et tous ces machins là
c'est pas le coiffeur du coin qui fait
vivre les grands journaux ou la télé
donc la publicité c'est un très très un
filtre très important le troisième
filtre important ce sont les relations
en entre les pouvoirs économiques
politiques et médiatiques il y a un très
bon bouquin malheureusement épuisé de
Geoffrey Goens tout pouvoir confondu où
il analyse toutes les grandes
multinationales européennes et des
États-Unis et il montre
l'enchevêtrement au niveau des
actionnaires et au niveau des
administrateurs vraiment toutes les
multinationales nationales pardon sont
les unes dans les autres et au niveau
des médias c'est très frappant j'ai
publié dans un de mes bouquins résumé de
ce qu'il avait travaillé et qui montre
que dans les médias aux États-Unis on a
les multinationales de la banque de la
chimie du pétrole de l'armement et
cetera qui sont dans les médias donc on
a des relations très très étroites et
puis il y a des relations de copinage on
va dire et d'élitisme entre les grands
directeurs les journalistes fe det euh
et les pouvoirs politique et économique
et le 4ème filtre ne doit pas être
négligé c'est la question de l'idéologie
dominante parce que je n'ai pas voulu
dire et je ne dirai jamais que tous les
journalistes sont pourris plein de
journalistes essayent de faire
correctement leur métier un en général
on leur laisse pas le temps
d'investiguer de faire des enquêtes il
faut produire vite c'est un travail à la
chaîne en fait et deux il y a quand même
aussi ce phénomène de l'idéologie on vit
dans une société on a été formé dans
lescs les journalistes aussi baignent
dans l'info qui est qui est diffusé et
ça c'est une idéologie une idéologie
dominante euh un patron de un
journaliste vet de TF1 disait au moment
de la guerre du Golfe là dont je parlais
la première disait voilà nous avons d'un
côté le monde civilisé et de l'autre
côté le monde arabe textuellement à
l'antenne donc on est dans une pensée
extrêmement raciste et colonialiste ça
ça reste très très fort Régis de Bré
avait dit cette phrase que j'aime
beaucoup de citer parlant justement de
ce phénomène de il disait
euh ils ont enlevé leur casque mais
dessous la tête est resté colonial le
mode de penser reste celui de l'Européen
blanc supérieur avec ses valeurs et que
les Arabes les noirs doivent apprendre
de l'Européen civilisé sur votre chaîne
Youtube vous avez annoncé il y a un ou
de mois que Laurent fabus et et le
gouvernement de François Hollande était
responsable des attentat
avec le Bataclan je crois bien par le
fait qu'ils a
le terrorisme est-ce que vous pouvez
rentrer plus en détail sur ces oui euh
ça ne vient pas de moi hein ça vient de
différents enquêteurs dont de nouveau
semch qui est un journaliste très très
intéressant qui devrait vraiment être
aux États-Unis donc qui devrait vraiment
être diffusé parce qu'il a les
confidences de gens de l'establishement
par exemple quand Obama ou Clinton
décide une guerre vous avez des généraux
qui sont pas d'accord qui disent on peut
pas la gagner ou ça va provoquer des
fait pire et donc qui balance des choses
et c'estes mot hech avait effectivement
euh avait fait des révélations euh par
rapport à tout ça
ouais ouis vas-y hein il avait fait des
révélations par rapport à tout ça il
avait dit
quoi j'ai oublié la question ah la
question c'était pourquoi vous
incriminiez Laurent fabus voilà dans les
attentats voilà et lui donc c'est mourur
a annoncé que
en
fait ce qu'on a appelé les
eurodjihadistes ces jeunes qui partent
se battent en Syrie le mot jihad ne
convient pas parce que dans le Coran le
djihad c'est essentiellement le combat
avec soi-même pour être un homme plus
juste donc ça n'a rien à voir mais ces
jeunes donc qui ont été envoyés là-bas
ça a été un travail
organisé par la CIA avec des campes
d'entraînement il a donné les dates et
les noms des lieux et même les
instructeurs ça a été financé par
l'Arabie saoudite et le Qatar nos chers
amis investisseurs dans notre économie
dans nots club sportifs et dans nos
restaurants
et prédicateur de haine un peu partout
c'est passé par la Turquie et donc on a
eu ce phénomène que les États-Unis et la
France avaient décidé de renverser le
gouvernement de Bachar alAssad c'est le
plan de recolonisation de l'ensemble du
Moyen-Orient après la Libye cétait la
Syrie puis ce sera le Hamas le hzbollah
et il voulait l'Iran mais ça ça va être
plus difficile en tout cas la résistance
palestinienne il faut la priver de tous
ces arrières et donc cette opération là
ça a été en fait étant donné que les
États-Unis Obama a compris l'échec de
bouche il n'est plus question d'envoyer
des troupes US au sol comme en Irak ou
en Afghanistan ça coûte cher on n'en
sort pas et on on devient une cible donc
on fait la guerre par proxy war comme
ils disent en anglais c'est-à-dire par
intermédiaire ça peut être des euh pays
voisins ou des mouvements
sécessionnistes ça ça marche parfois
mais en Syrie il y avait pas les forces
pour faire ça donc les seules forces
qu'ils ont trouvé c'est de constituer
une armée d'eurodjihadiste quand même
35000 venu de toute une série de pays
avec l'argent de l'Arabie Saoudite et du
Qatar pour financer ça et c'est pas
nouveau c'est exactement ce qui avait
été fait contre l'Afghanistan
l'opération Ben Laden breginski dont je
parle l'avait organisé et c'est en fait
une opération Ben Laden bis donc quand
j'ai dit que Fabius et compagnie étaient
responsable des attentats de Paris c'est
parce qu'en fait ces
gens-là les gens qui ont fait ça ont été
envoyés en Syrie pour faire ça contre la
population syrienne parce que on
massacre des chrétiens des musulmans
donc là c'est le chien qui se retourne
contre la M c'est exactement oui comment
vous voyez le les 30 prochaines
années sur le sur le prisme de lecture
terroriste de cette grande nébuleuse
terroriste sur le plan du terrorisme je
pense que c'est devenu une arme
privilégiée des États-Unis et de leurs
alliés mais c'est les États-Unis qui
sont le maître d'œuvre là-dedans
pourquoi parce que comme je le disais
les États-Unis n'osent plus envoyer
leurs troupes occuper un pays comme il
faisait avant ça il s'expose ça coûte
cher ça soude la population contre eux
donc c'est pas productif donc on est
obligé de trouver des remplacements
alors évidemment ils ont essayer aussi
de faire en sorte que les Européens se
battent pour eux et financent une partie
de leur guerre mais ça ça marche moyen
donc on essaie de trouver des puissances
locales parfois ça marche Israël
évidemment il vit sur
l'industrie de guerre donc Israël ne
demande que ça la Colombie était aussi
un peu
l'Israël de l'Amérique latine on va dire
l'Éthiopie est aussi dans la Corne de
l'Afrique est une région stratégique
c'est aussi un pays qui sert de de de
flic local on va dire aux États-Unis
mais il y a des limites à ça aussi et
donc maintenant le terrorisme c'est
vraiment une arme privilégié et c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est un psychiatre
célèbre en France qui s'appelle Boris
nique il a fait une déclaration très peu
de temps après l'attentat contre Charlie
qui était très
significative on lui demandait j'imagine
en tant que psychiatre qu'il a dû avoir
des des jeunes ou des familles de jeunes
qui sont venus le voir en étant parti
là-bas et moi j'ai rencontré des mamans
dont les gosses sont partis là-bas et je
peux vous dire que c'est vraiment
humainement quelque chose d'horrible à à
entendre et donc je suis sûr sir a
rencontré des gens et donc il a été
révolté par la la façon de parler de
l'histoire de Charlie en noyant le
poisson et en ne parlant pas des des
vrais problème qui est responsable de de
cette chos là et si le journaliste lui
disait mais cunque disait ce sont des
filières très organisées qui recrutent
les jeunes avec un lavage de cerveau ça
je l'ai vu aussi les méthodes qui
sonemploi pour on prend des jeunes de 15
16 17 ans qui sont en adolescence ou
paumés c'est facile de manipuler et donc
culnick disait c'est des filières bien
organisées alors le journaliste lu dit
filière de qui et il dit par les gens du
pétrole et de la drogue très clairement
parce que c'est un moyen pas cher pour
déstabiliser des gouvernements et
contrôler des régions et des ressources
donc je crois que c'est ça le point
fondamental c'est que le gouvernement
français et ses alliés ne sont pas la la
solution face au problème du terreur
ils sont la cause du problème et les
États-Unis qui sont évidemment les
maîtres d'œuvre sont ceux qui utilisent
à une grande échelle le terrorisme il
faut rappeler qu'ils l'ont fait contre
Cuba qui ont fait contre le Venezuela
contre des pays latino-américains on a
financé des coups de la CIA pour faire
exploser un avion avec des sportifs
cubains ou dans des hôtels à La Havane
donc et ils sont réfugés à Miami les
gens estce que vous pouvez nous parler
des réseaux gladiux
oui ben les réseaux Gladio pour les
jeunes c'est un phénomène très important
dans les les années 50 au moment de la
guerre froide moi j'ai vécu ça j'étais
petit garçon dans les années 50 on était
éduqué dans les Russes vont nous
attaquer les Russes vont envahir
l'Europe et on va tous devenir être
obbligé de communist de tevenir par les
Russes être communiste on devra on va
perdre notre maison on va perdre notre
voiture on devra partager les femmes
parce que c on était vraiment dans les
trucs incroyables sur la propagande on
partage jamais les hommes c'est dommage
ah non c'est vraiment c'est fort et donc
on
a l'OTAN a organiser des réseaux pour le
cas où il y aurait des gouvernements de
gauche qui viendraient en Europe c'était
surtout la France et l'Italie un peu la
Belgique aussi parce que à années 50
après 40 45 le capitalisme a produit la
deuxème guerre mondial les patrons en
France ont beaucoup collaboré avec le
nazisme en Belgique sont réfugiés à
l'onde en attendant que ce soit fini ù
ont collaboré à Bruxelles aussi et donc
les gens ont compris que la guerre
mondiale est le produit du capitalisme
en tant que lutte pour la suprématie
mondiale les matières premières les
colonies que c'est une guerre pour le
fric tout simplement r GL et donc ils
cherchent autre chose et les réseaux
gladiux c'est au cas où ces gens
décideraient qu'ils veulent un
gouvernement de gauche avec des
communistes on va faire des attentats on
va déstabiliser le pays on va semer la
terreur pour il y a eu des des attentats
et il y a eu des attentats il y a eu des
attentats dans années 50 il y a eu des
attentats à la gare de Bologne avec je
crois 280 ou 300 morts on a mis des
bombes à la Guer de Bologne et qu'est-ce
qu'on a dit c'est les anarchistes et
donc ça sert à faire passer des lois
répressives contre la gauche et en
réalité ça a été reconnu par un
organisateur de l'attentat en réalité
c'était une provocation des réseaux
Gladio et de l'OTAN pour semer le bordel
en Italie flanquer la trouille on
revient à ce qu'on avait abordé tout à
l'heure aux Italiens allez il nous faut
un gouvernement de droite il faut des
lois très fortes donc c'est la le
recours au terrorisme pour déstabiliser
vous avez vu euh en France on a eu
récemment une grande campagne contre les
théories du complot les complotistes et
les les casques en aluminium
et est-ce que vous pensez que puisque
notre histoire n'est pas assez énoncée
clairement comme les réseaux Gladio
comme les gens ne savent pas ça est-ce
que cette antériorité historique est
utilisée par les ce que nous on appelle
les nouveaux gourous qui dis voilà les
réseaux Gladio bah ils nous l'ont mis à
l'envers les attentats Coulibali c'est
la même chose alors nous on n'est pas du
tout d'accord avec cette vision là
l'histoire de le le rétroviseur qui
passe du noir à l'argent mais c'était
pas la bonne voiture
mais on n'est pas trop d'accord avec ça
on n pas même du tout d'accord avec ça
est-ce que vous pensez que pour
supprimer certaines théories du complot
il faudrait se retourner sur notre passé
pour au G ça s'est produit mais là sur
ce coup-là c'est pas le cas h qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez tout à fait je pense
que la question des complots du
complotisme des obsédés de la thorie du
complot c'est une question importante
euh je suis en train de travailler
là-dessus et ça va sortir bientôt
euh en fait il faut dire un que les
complots ça existe je veux dire quand
les États-Unis organisent le
renversement d'ind pour le remplacer par
le fasciste Pinochet le meurtre de MBA
par mobutou oui c'est un
complot ça existe sur le plan politique
sur le plan économique sur le plan
militaire aussi quand Bush et Blair
disent il faut attaquer Sadam parce
qu'il a des armes de destruction massive
et qui savent que c'est faux ben c'est
un complot c'est la définition du
dictionnaire sur un complot deuxièmement
il faut dire
que c'est pas l'histoire ne se résume
pas à des complots et c'est même pas
l'essentiel tout à l'heure j'ai essayé
d'expliquer que le système économique et
social dans lequel on vit il est injuste
parce qu'il est basé sur le fait que 1 %
décide de ce qu'on va produire dans les
usines et ailleurs de comment va
l'économie va être organisée qui va
avoir de l'argent qui va pas en avoir
mais ça c'est pas un complot ce sont des
règles de fonctionnement économique et
c'est pas quelque chose qu'il contrôle
vraiment que vous voyez avec vos yeux de
d'anciens militants communistes ou des
choses comme ça non vous avez une vision
de gauche mais c'est clair que l'analyse
de Marx permet de comprendre comment
fonctionne l'économie et je suis je
pense qu'il faut éviter les les lancé
d'étiquettes et que les étiquettes c'est
ce qui a marqué sur votre fiche
Wikipédia ah oui bien sûr mais non mais
que ce soit à propos de moi ou à propos
de n'importe qui je n'ai pas honte de je
crois que il faut réfléchir avec son
cerveau et on a intérêt à ce qu'un
public large se pose des questions sur
comment fonctionne l'économie comment
fonctionne la politique comment se
décident les guerres et aussi étudier
l'histoire qui permet énormément de
comprendre l'époque actuel donc sans les
étiquettes oui je pense que l'économie
Marx a très bien expliqué comment ça se
fait qu'il y en a qui sont très riches
et qui sont très pauvres et qu'il y a un
lien entre les deux c'est des vastes
communicquants là Hugo avant Marx ou en
même temps mais je crois pas qu'il se
connaissaiit avait dit c'est de l'enfer
des pauvres qui fait le paradis des
riches donc c'est un bon résumé de
l'exploitation
et je crois
que il
faut pas expliquer ça en terme de
complot qu'il y a quelques personnes
dans une banque dans une des banquiers
ou des juifs ou des Illuminati qui sont
dans une cave et qui décident qu'on va
faire une crise comme ça on va et des
choses pareilles ça c'est des fantasmes
et on voit beaucoup de fantasmes et de
théories du complot pour expliquer le
monde pour une raison bien simple c'est
que les médias ne permettent pas de
comprendre le monde les médias cachent à
chaque guerre la vérité cach le
fonctionnement de l'économie je veux
dire on a invite tout le temps des des
économistes qui serinent que le 1 % a
raison et qu'il a pas d'alternative et
tous les autres sont sont boycottés donc
évidemment que les gens se posent des
questions comme ils n'ont pas la réponse
ils vont chercher sur internet sur
internet on peut trouver de bonnes
choses et de moins bonnes et forcément
ils peuvent tomber dans des pièges et
c'est très important effectivement
d'étud l'histoire mais aussi l'économie
la les stratégies de guerre parce que
moi je pense que souvent on dit ces
trucsl c'est trop compliqué les gens
vont pas comprendre donc on simplifie
non il faut essayer
de communiquer l'essentiel de donner des
faits de permettre aux gens de réfléchir
dans un langage simple avec des mots que
tout le monde comprend et tout le monde
peut comprendre moi j'ai déjà donné des
formations sur l'économie ou la
philosophie ou les stratégies de guerre
à des ouvriers qui avaient arrêté les
écoles à l'étude à 16 ans à des
ménagèures qui avaient jamais fait
d'études et donc tout le monde peut
comprendre ça et je vaux dire les gens
d'en bas parfois comprendront beaucoup
mieux euh le fond des choses que les
gens qui croient qu' avec leur grande
éducation ils savent tout et je crois
que c'est ça pour répondre à cette
histoire du complot les médias
n'informant pas refusant le débat avec
les gens qui défendent d'autres points
de vue une autre analyse ou d'autres
sources tout simplement queeux il
provoque ce sentiment on nous cache tout
donc on va chercher des choses midi à
14h alors que le monde est parfaitement
connaissable et analysable s'il y a une
vraie info correcte et c'est ça qu'avec
investi action on essaie de faire donner
aux citoyens les moyens eux-mêmes
d'analyser le monde et de se faire leur
opinion vous vous avez parlé des Balcans
on va revenir sur sur les Balcans est-ce
que vous connaissez le général westle
Clark bien sûr est-ce que vous
connaissez ces déclarations ah oui cité
dans qu'est-ce qu' dit qui est ce
monsieur et et qu'est-ce qu'il a fait
ben westlecar qui est un général qui a
bombardé la Yougoslavie et j'étais sur
place pendant les bombardements il était
le chef d'étatmajor de l'OTAN donc
c'était le chef des opération et je peux
témoigner que c'est un criminel de
guerre s'il y avait une justice
internationale il aurait dû être jugé
parce que j'ai été sur place j'ai vu des
hôpitaux bombardés j'ai vu qu'ils
étaient venus bombarder un hôpital j'ai
j'ai vu une infirmière en entendant
qu'il y avait les sirènes s'est dit elle
é en mais ma place est à l'hôpital elle
arrive à l'hôpital ils reviennent
bombarder une deuxième fois pas
bombarder je veux dire avec des bombes à
fragmentation donc elle a été utée
c'était vraiment terrible j'ai vu des
des gosses j'ai vu des usines détruites
comme par hasard toutes les usines qui
étaient nationalisé youoslav ont été
détruit et toutes les usines qui
appartenaient à des multinationales
étrangères cell-là étit intacte donc
c'était vraiment une guerre économique
dégueulasse et Clark était un criminel
de guerre ça c'est clair ça donne
d'autant plus de poids à la déc aration
très intéressante qu'il a faite en 2005
ou en 2007 je sais plus je crois 2005 il
était interviewé par une radio que je
connais où j'avais été qui s'appelle
démocracy now par Amy Goodman aux
États-Unis et il a fait une confidence
très intéressante il était à la retraite
tout de suite après la Yougoslavie et
donc il s'amène au Pentagone fin 2001
après le 11 septembre novembre décembre
je crois la date dans un de mes bouquins
et il rencontre un général avec qui il
était copain et ce général lui dit voilà
je viens de recevoir un mémo d'en haut
donc de rsfeld le ministre de la guerre
et le mémo dit nous allons nous
États-Unis nous allons prendre SEP pays
en commençant par l'Irak
l'Afghanistan le Soudan la Libye le
Liban la Somalie et pour finir l'Iran 7
pays en
2001 donc ça veut dire que tout ça é
programmé après on dit oui c'est parce
que sadame a des des armes de druction
massive parce que le Soudan ils font
ceci ou ils font ça ou Kaddafi la c'est
tout programmé et après on saute sur le
prétexte ou on fabrique le prétexte et
donc
est les clar c'est un aveu très
intéressant parce que c'est pas un type
de gauche c'est pas un complotiste il
dit lui-même voilà les États-Unis ils
ont un plan pour recoloniser tout le
monde arabo mususulman et ça on l'a
analysé dans un bouquin qui s'appelle la
stratégie du chaos impérialisme mais
Islam les États-Unis décident de
contrôler ce qu'ils appellent l'arc
islamique Moyen-Orient Maghreb mais
aussi la Corne de l'Afrique avec deux
pays stratégiques le le Soudan et la
Somalie et l'Afghanistan et le Pakistan
qui sont euh l'Afghanistan c'est la
plaque tournante au point de vue
stratégique de de l'Asie pour menacer la
Chine et le Pakistan c'est la zone
centrale pour les voies de l'océan
Indien parce que on pense toujours en
terme de pays au niveau stratégique mais
il faut penser en terme d'océan les
routes maritimes il y en a 60 %
maintenant qui sont dans l'océan Indien
c'est plus
Atlantique l'Atlantique ou même le
Pacifique c'est l'océan Indien qui est
le centre du monde et donc le Pakistan
voilà mais je m'entraî TR par connaissz
le collier de perle oui c'est ça la
sécurisation du collier de perle oui
voilà les les chinois ayant peu de
matièrees premières et une économie qui
se développe énormément
sont obligés de se procurer des matières
premières là où il y en a et donc c'est
par là que les États-Unis veulent les
tenir évidemment les États-Unis ne sont
pas tout à fait fous et ils ne peuvent
pas imaginer d'attaquer militairement la
Chine ce serait impossible donc il faut
l'encercler il faut la priver au pouvoir
la priver de ses approvisionnements en
matières premières donc il y a une
guerre pour les matières premières et ce
que la Chine veut faire c'est un réseau
de port en eau profonde parce que le
commerce maritime international
maintenant c'est des pororts en eau
profonde et
voilà tout ce collier de perles
effectivement toute cette cette chaîne
de port en eau profonde les États-Unis
dès qu'il y a un partenaire ou un allié
pour la Chine ils essayent de
déstabiliser coup d'État guerre civile
ou corruption pour essayer de prendre le
contrôle ils l'ont fait récemment au Sri
Lanka c'est vraiment très important pour
eux de contrôler l'océan Indien la
papoisie Nouvelle-Guinée qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire en ce moment tu
pas spécialiste je passe d'accord euh
comment ça va se terminer
sur le plan des guerres sur le plan de
terrorisme ou en général Guer ou sur le
plan des guerres parce que là on voit la
Russie faire énormément de mouvements on
voit la Chine construire des des
pores-avions fixes avec des îles
artificielles
et on voit les contrats d'armement un
petit peu les alliances soudé un peu à
gauche et à droite nous l'Europe on est
au milieu on comment ça va se terminer
va la guerre ou on va pas la guerre
cette personne peut le prédire
l'histoire n'est pas prévisible sur ce
plan-là les deux peuvent arriver il y a
toute une série j'ai publié il y a
quelques mois une série d'articles Obama
craint un conflit mondial je crois c'est
ça le titre analysant un discours très
étonnant qu'il a
fait au moment où
il il a présenté les l'accord conclu
avec l'Iran il avait évidemment une
opposition très forte for des
républicains au Congrès même chez des
démocrates aussi qui disaiit il faut pas
euh faire un accord avec l'Iran il faut
les attaquer il faut continuer et il a
dit Obama si vous attaquez l'Iran 1 ça
va pas du tout
euh faire le bien des États-Unis parce
que l'Iran nous résiste il nous s'est
pas mis à genou deux ça va nous
discréditer au point de vue
international jusqu'à présent on a pu
compter sur l'aide de la France et des
Européens pour faire la guerre contre la
Libye ou la Syrie mais si on fait ça
tout seul étant donné que Peugeot et
compagnie ne rêve que d'une chose c'est
des contrats de téran ils vont pas nous
suivre c'est fini les Allemands non plus
n'en veulent pas donc il a dit à ses
opposants aux États-Unis il faut arrêter
de penser qu'on peut faire la guerre
contre l'Iran et il a dit aussi une
chose intéressante il a dit euh on va
pas pouvoir contrerer comme ça la
volonté des Russes et des Chinois
indéfiniment les chinois ils possèdent
une grande partie de la dette des
États-Unis parce que l'état des
États-Unis est un état en faillite s'il
n'y a pas les pétromonarchies et la
Chine pour financer sa dette l'économie
est en faillite littéralement et donc il
a dit voilà si on fait ça on va
affaiblir terriblement les États-Unis
alors on se trouve maintenant dans une
période historique très importante et
très dangereuse en fait il y a deux
courants aux États-Unis il y a le
courant qui
dit nous sommes en déclin économiquement
financièrement militairement il faut
essayer d'être malin il faut faire des
guerres sans que ça se voit trop il faut
toujours avoir des alliés il faut
essayer de neutraliser ce les puissances
qui pourrai s'opposer il faut faire la
guerre intelligemment et ça veut dire
aussi par la corruption par la CIA par
des guerres civiles et de la façon la
moins visible possible ça c'est un
courant c'est Obama c'est Brezinski des
gens comme ça l'autre courant c'est le
courant néocon on va dire buche mais
Hillary Clinton elle est plutôt de ce
courant-l il faut pas croire c'est pas
parce que c'est pas républicain ou
démocrate Bernie suunders tu dit comment
là-dedans ah oui non là je pense que ça
je voterai pour lui aux États-Unis si
j'étais là mais je veux dire que les
néocones ont un plan que au contraire il
faut aller à la confrontation avec la
Russie qu'il faut pas laisser faire
Poutine et donc on le provoque on est en
train de le provoquer de toutes les
manières pour essayer de faire une
escalade et les néocon sont décidés à
faire ce qu'il faut pour briser la
résistance de la Russie de la Chine de
l'Iran bien entendu
là il nous emmène vers une 3è guerre
mondiale pas programmé ou voulu mais
quand on lance une escalade contre
d'autres puissance de cette manière-là
quand on refuse de négocier et de
trouver des solutions diplomatiques
c'est clair que ça peut mener sur un
conflit épouvantable les préconisations
pour éviter le conflit épouvantable la
chose qui manque terriblement en Europe
et aux États-Unis mais bon je parler en
tant qu'Européen c'est un mouvement
anti-uerre il y a eu des des
manifestations j'en parlais avec des
millions de gens dans le monde contre la
guerre du Vietnam encore en 2003 contre
la guerre en Irak mais à part ça quand
les États-Unis ou la France attaqueent
un pays et que ce pays soit une
démocratie ou une dictature ça ne change
rien parce que c'est pas une question
pas ça guerre pour le FRC quand on
attaque des pays quand on fait la guerre
il y a personne dans les rues maintenant
c'est ça qui est dramatique c'est que on
a eu dans le passé des mouvements
antiguerre puissant dans les années 30
dans les années 50 et encore après on a
eu des dockers qui refusaient de charger
les armements on a eu des ouvriers qui
se mettaient en grève on a eu des
sabotages de train on a eu des
mouvements de solidarité très
importantes on a eu des appels
d'intellectuels pour la paix des
réunions des forums Bertand Russel
tribunaux tout ça et maintenant c'est
complètement disparu et il y a un
phénomène terrible en France et dans les
autres pays
européens c'est que la gauche qui
devrait le faire mais je parle pas de
Monsieur Hollande hein ça je parle pas
de ça c'est pas la gauche pour moi mais
même à gauche du PS les gens qui devrait
être en première ligne contre la guerre
pour la paix pour le dialogue
international pour le respect de la la
souveraineté des nations euh basculle et
soutiennent les guerres de l'OTAN en
disant oui il faut faire quelque chose
ind dictateur et à ceci à cela comme si
le but des États-Unis et de la France
était de d'amener la démocratie partout
dans le monde ils font ça ça avec l'aide
de l'Arabie Saoudite et du Qatar donc
forcément il se payent la gueule des
gens donc je crois que ça c'est le drame
maintenant la gauche a complètement
capitulé devant les guerres que
j'appelle coloniales n'os plus dire que
on nous ment à chaque guerre et n'ose
plus organiser la solidarité avec les
pays du Sud et là on revient à cette
phrase de Debray que je cite tout le
temps il y a une mentalité coloniale une
mentalité arrogante en France et en
Europe nous les blancs les bons on sait
ce qu'il faut faire partout dans le
monde on sait ce que les Arabes les
Africains les latines doivent faire mais
non on est pourquoi on saurait plus que
pourquoi on aurait la solution
laissez-les se débrouiller pour résoudre
leurs problèmes et ça l'absence d'un
mouvement anti-uerre pour moi c'est une
chose terrible parce que comme je le
disais on est sur le sentier de la
guerre ça peut arriver ce n'est pas une
fatalité mais la résistance elle est où
dernière question un conseil pour les
jeunes génération pour endurcir l'esprit
critique se forgerou ça c'est
l'essentiel
je crois que la jeune génération a
vraiment
intérêt si elle veut vit dans un monde
qui soit pas épouvantable au niveau des
guerres de la destruction de la nature
et de cette manière de répandre la haine
que tout le monde se déteste dans tous
les sens je crois que la jeune
génération a vraiment intérêt à prendre
en main son combat pour la justice pour
la paix pour la nature et que le combat
il passe par la question de l'info et
donc investigaction c'est de ça qu'on
s'occupe on est un média c'est ça notre
métier on va dire il est pas possible de
faire la guerre sans manipuler les gens
donc il est très important de vérifier
les infos et je parle de guerre déclarée
ou non déclarée de guerre militaire ou
de guerre sociale ou culturelle et
cetera il faut vérifier les infos
absolument il et c'est tout à fait
possible il faut que l'info devienne
quelque chose qui n'est pas réservé aux
experts professionnels mais devienent
une activité citoyenne c'est trop
important l'info pour notre vie
aujourd'hui et demain à tous pour la
laisser aux mains de gens pour qui c'est
soit du fric soit des intérêts de
propagande il faut que l'info soit faite
par les citoyens je pense que ça devrait
commencer à l'école mais là je rêve et
donc il faut organiser des ateliers
parallèles ou avec les profs qui sont
motivés là-dessus mais en parallèle il
faut organiser des ateliers pour
apprendre à regarder la télé les images
les manipulations que ça peut entraîner
pour apprendre à faire une analyse
critique sur les infos qu'on reçoit à
chercher les sources à chercher l'autre
version à écouter les méchants et à se
faire son opinion par soi-même je pense
c'est quelque chose que je dis très
souvent c'est qui est méchant si on veut
se battre c'est qui les méchants ben les
méchants c'est toujours ceux qui sont
pas d'accord avec nous ceux qui sont pas
d'accord de donner le le pétrole
gratuitement ou le cuivre ou le coltan
ou euh les le canal de suè ou le canal
de Panama les méchants c'est ceux ceux
qui sont pas d'accord avec le 1 % des
multinationales c'est ceux-là qui sont
diabolisés et donc je crois que si on
veut vraiment comme je le
dis créer un monde et je pense vraiment
que c'est possible quand je sais pas
mais je pense vraiment que c'est
possible créer un monde où il y aura
plus l'exploitation et tous les uns
contre les autres et la haine et la
destruction de la nature je pense que
l'info est la première des batailles et
c'est pour ça que le premier conseil que
je donne aux jeunes et à tout le monde
c'est d'appliquer cette idée prendre en
main la bataille de l'info c'est-à-dire
nous sommes tous des journalistes Michel
colon merci merci à vous
[Musique]